well Boeing has apologized for
communications released to US Congress
and the FAA that called design those of
the 737 max quote clowns supervised by
monkeys the statements were made in
instant messages released as part of an
investigation into two deadly crashes
involving the aircraft where Boeing says
the comments are unacceptable and don't
reflect the planes integrity well
Matthew Driscoll is an editor of Asian
Aviation he joins us on skype from
Singapore Matthew very warm welcome to
the program
this is deeply embarrassing isn't it at
a real time of crisis for Boeing that's
the understatement of the year I would
say hugely embarrassing and it's also
dangerous
it's it's dangerous obviously for Boeing
itself but for the people that the
pilots the test pilots the people that
were involved in sending these emails
it's dangerous because if they are
proven if it's proven that they actually
lied to a federal official someone from
the Federal Aviation Administration for
example if it's proven that they lied to
them that's a felony
they could go to prison for that
secondly and this is a bit theoretical
that I was raised by lawyers my mother
was a lawyer my brother who bailed his
brother was a lawyer if in the process
of committing a felony somebody dies
then theoretically you could be charged
with murder for that so if prosecutors
could tie everything together and say
this person lied and because of that lie
the plane was approved etc etc
theoretically you could have 346 counts
of murder on there now that that's a bit
of a stretch admittedly and I don't mean
to to blow everything out of proportion
I'm just trying to demonstrate how
serious this is because if you lie to a
federal official in the United States
that's a felony and someone could go to
but someone could go to prison for that
Matthieu considering that this message
came from an employee does it raise yet
more questions about the 737 max well
it's not just a 737 max as well it's the
triple 7x it's the 787 there have been
all kinds of
inside our complaints filed by Boeing
employees that there is sloppiness on
the production line that that Boeing and
is putting profit over people or profit
over safety and and any kind of you know
part of the problem is it's this
constant drip drip drip of bad
information that keeps coming out and it
just seems that that Boeing is digging
the hole deeper about it and it raises a
lot of questions I mean for me
personally I fly a lot and I have
concerns about getting on the Boeing
plane now and I think Matthew the booby
certain members of the flying public who
would agree with you and that I want to
have this complicates Boeing's
relationship further with the FAA and in
the future could we see repercussions as
far as Boeing perhaps having to to
separate the different parts of its
operation that's an excellent question
the in they've had trouble with the FAA
and before Dennis Muhlenberg the former
CEO before he was fired or resigned from
Boeing he was having problems because he
was trying to pressure the FAA into
approving the Mac's to come back into
the air I read a column if you'd ask me
that question before I would say no
there's no way they're going to separate
the businesses Boeing however has a huge
is probably one of the largest if not
the largest defense contractors in the
world and if you'd asked me that three
months ago I woulda said no it's not
possible
but I read a very interesting column the
other day where they talked about just
that that thing of separating the
defense business and splitting off the
commercial airline business and make no
mistake the commercial airline business
will still be around for a long time
there are thousands of Boeing planes
flying they're gonna need to be serviced
there they will they have a lot of life
in them so Boeing planes aren't gonna go
anywhere so that business is still
viable but as it stands right now it is
going to be a drag on Boeing's earnings
for a long time to come
Matthew Driscoll their editor of Asian
Aviation joining us from Singapore
Matthew thank you thank you